we are ready to go and we're underway and the
coyotes will possess a massive test here for
the cootes up against the defending Stanley Cup
champions doesn't get any bigger than this Vegas
golden knights coming off that win against the
Edmonton Oilers two nights ago snap their win
streak at 16 barbashev to the front and they
score and it's Jonathan maraso opening minute
goal one- nothing Vegas absolute Advantage Vegas
golden knights ready to start this hockey game
real good movement and Jonathan Maro the guy
we talked about the open of the show how about
nine goals now in his last nine games and we're
only 20 seconds into this one well they had the
hattrick at New York against the Rangers on the
26th of January he's at it early here tonight Marc
so and that goal assisted by Ivan barbashev and
Nick w w has been redot as well and I know both
of these teams have greats I I get that but
cumulatively as this one is play by H and it
flooders in and two nothing just like that Vegas
well a little mullet magic is in favor of the
Vegas colon Knights two goals and Andre turny not
happy with his Club this a test this a measuring
stick this the defending Stanley Cup champions
you've got to be ready to start this hockey game
let's see how they respond a little bit of
a a crazy bounce there iies have now allowed
seven first period goals over the last four games
they're down two nothing and a chance to move it
out as Lawson Krauss could handle it mbad sweeps
in kind I think so far steadied the ship a little
bit after the first two goals out high bami they
score and I think it may have been deflected by
Jason zooker coyotes are on the board oh you bet
you and it was zooker on the coyotes bench it was
just giving it to guys is absolutely key look
at the pressure the K forced to turn over back
to balamaki look at zoker goes right to the cage
right in front of Hill and the redirection post
and in Big Goal for zooker that's his eigh of the
season and it's a big one Mar goes down down the
length back to Center Ice Paul
cter and intercepting that was K
but Stevenson has it and he's scores
Chandler Stevenson has made it 3 to
one now again Andre turny shaking his head on
the bench he is not happy about the coverage
there's the pinch JJ Moser gets caught up
byce therey back and that is one that Conor
Ingram has got a stop not sure if that goes
off the Stick of Shawn Jersy I don't think
it did no that was straight in and the
golden knights will get it set up buat
out there with kerfoot Dumba and dermit
to kill off this coyotes penalty across
for stone and they work it out high baram on
off and now maraso in tight and a shot and a
goal William Carlson he had Conor Ingram looking
the other away and it's a 4-1 game and the referee
adamant that this one went in as he walks Corner
Ingram and his his movement they're zipping it
around and Carlson knocks this one out of midair
with his body and then down to his stick and I
think his stick is let's see if the contact is
made with a stick if not this oh yeah absolutely
that's a that's a good goal yeah nothing wrong
with that one it's going to go 41 Vegas and we got
two more looks for you here and this Puck comes
off the Stick of stone off the right shoulder
right there at Carlson that forearm actually his
stick comes down but doesn't make contact with
the puck as it goes off that right skate of Conor
Ingram impossible to see from that angle here's
Kevin poock after video review it's determined
that the Vegas player batted the puck with the
glove all right it deflected off the goalie
and went in therefore we have no goal he did
not touch the P so so what do you do here now you
put Conor Ingram back in the net for Andre turny
so was determined that it was batted in with he'd
rather not have it Stevenson down low to the front
ow and Carlson with a great look on Carell Thea
that's a lot of rubber out of his zone for cter
and now Stevenson will bring it along AC cross
Stone looking to drop for mcmah stone gets it
back that's other the Vegas B kns Defenders
do they they use the whole Zone The Defenders
are almost outside the blue line when they get
that PO run beard maybe saving a goal was the
Stick of Matias melli as the Vegas golden night
big stop by carala not once but twice that left
pad up obviously when you have a coach like that
you that's your leader ultimately and the players
love playing for brought back in stone for cter
and a stop from Ela going to be outdone as you
look at Stone Zips it across Cur foot side of
the net flipped to the front that was valami
in behind the net looking for a centering feed
here's another chance Cur fooot right to the
front big Jam away and carcone is in there as
well but it's Hill with the cover for so much
room and here's kerit taking it hard to the net
one chance two chances played into the corner b
Sun that'll be brought out kep by corac
Carlson a little drop and set wide at
the horn that what have counted that he's made
here tonight and this is a beauty Carlson with
a setup a left pad has been very active
here tonight taking away the lower part
PL that they had and he took over that
took advantage of his opportunity as
mcdal cleared out it's brought along Nick
Nick W's got it w shoots stopped by caraa
here's a chance Keller is in Keller
scores one goal game early in the
third oh you bet you and how about
that stop by carala Mala back it
comes the other way Clayton Keller right
place right time and he just tucks it in
that is a goal scorer's goal right there
if you've ever seen it stick side below
the blocker into the corner Lawson cruss
here's a chance bu stab batted Away by
hill now melli working the board across buad in
front and leading that time to make the save aen
hill comes out High buat another shot he'll the
sa for valami an ey that came in front chance
Ward oh just sent wide what a look Nick wah
yeah back door tapping and McNab and another
save of Mila nearly an opportunity almost swung
with bu stats set up by melli and a turnover
here Barber is in in barers right to the net
oh what a stop but the counties had to look
the other way Barbers holds off the defender
sha dery and carala Superman across the blue
paint and he just gets enough of that I believe
with his blocker amio thought he had one oh yeah
just gets a stick on it play to the middle
[__] they get it over the line kie trying
to swat at it w looking to get it out and that's
going to do it the Vegas golden knights survive